Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is ther, Spaniard. I don't think there's ever been a gladiator to match you. As for this young man, he insists you are Hector Reborn. Or was it Hercules? Why doesn't the hero reveal himself and tell us all your real name? You do have a name.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。那是你，西班牙人。我想从来没有角斗士能与你匹敌。至于这个年轻人，他坚持说你是赫克托耳转世。还是赫拉克勒斯？英雄为什么不现身，告诉我们你真正的名字？你肯定有个名字。
My name is Gladiator. How dare you show your back to me? Slave, you will remove your helmet and tell me your name. My name is Maximus Decimus Meridius, Commander of the Armies of the North, General of the Felix Legions, and loyal servant to the true Emperor, Marcus Aurelius. Father to a murdered son, husband to a murdered wife,
我的名字是角斗士。你竟敢背对着我？奴隶，摘下你的头盔，告诉我你的名字。我的名字是马克西姆斯·德西姆斯·梅里迪乌斯，北方军团指挥官，菲利克斯军团将军，忠诚于真正的皇帝马可·奥勒留。是一个被谋杀的儿子的父亲，一个被谋杀的妻子的丈夫，
and I will have my vengeance in this life or the next. Brilliant, Dominic. So that was me as the Emperor Commodus, and that was you as Maximus. As Russell Crowe, Tom. Played by Russell Crowe and Joachim Phoenix, respectively, from Gladiator, of course, which is set in the arena of death, the greatest and most celebrated stage in the whole of history, perhaps, the Coliseum. So that was one of the first great achievements of CGI, I think, in cinema.
我会在今生或来世复仇。太精彩了，多米尼克。所以那是扮演康茂德皇帝的我，而那是扮演马克西姆斯的你。当然是罗素·克劳，汤姆。分别由罗素·克劳和杰昆·菲尼克斯在《角斗士》中饰演，这部电影的背景是死亡竞技场，这或许是整个历史上最伟大、最著名的舞台——罗马斗兽场。我认为那是电影史上CGI技术的首批伟大成就之一。
I think it was defining. I think it absolutely was. I remember I saw that film, Gladiator. I was doing my PhD research. I was in Washington, DC, and I took the day off from working at the National Archives because I was so excited about Gladiator. And it was one of those films that I felt that when I was watching it, it wasn't just that I was watching it, but there was a sort of the ghost of my 10-year-old self. Yeah, me too. Sitting next to me, watching it, and just in awe
我认为它是决定性的。我绝对这么认为。我记得我看了那部电影《角斗士》。当时我正在做博士研究。我在华盛顿特区，我从国家档案馆请了一天假，因为我对《角斗士》太兴奋了。那是那种让我觉得在观看时，不仅仅是在看电影，而是我10岁时的灵魂仿佛也在场。是的，我也是。坐在我旁边，看着它，只是对那种奇观感到敬畏，
at the spectacle of something that I had probably always dreamed one way I would see on screen, but never thought I really would. So I say that it was defining for CGI because the artificiality of it, in a sense, was the whole point. The reproduction of the Colosseum was vastly exaggerated. It made it look much, much bigger than it really was, but that was absolutely appropriate because everything about the Colosseum, it's all about spectacle, show, illusion, exaggeration. So just to have reproduced it would have been completely untrue, ironically enough, to the actual spirit of the original structure. Because it wouldn't have awed us in the same way the Colosseum awed people in the first or
那是我可能一直梦想在银幕上看到，但从未想过真的能看到的景象。所以我说它对CGI具有决定性意义，因为从某种意义上说，它的虚构性正是重点所在。斗兽场的复制品被极大地夸张了。它看起来比实际大得多，但这绝对是恰当的，因为关于斗兽场的一切，都是关于奇观、表演、幻觉和夸张。所以，仅仅是复制它，讽刺的是，反而完全背离了原始建筑的真正精神。因为它不会像斗兽场在公元一世纪或
second century AD. And are you not entertained? It's all about entertainment. So in a way, the film Gladiator perfectly kind of mapped onto the way that the original Colosseum functioned. So I thought it was absolutely fantastic. But isn't there a fascinating thing with the Colosseum? And indeed, the film Gladiator captures this perfectly, which is we're simultaneously dazzled by the spectacle and thrilled by the excitement.
二世纪那样让人们感到敬畏。难道你们不觉得娱乐吗？一切都是为了娱乐。所以从某种程度上说，《角斗士》这部电影完美地映射了原始斗兽场的运作方式。所以我认为它绝对棒极了。但关于斗兽场，难道没有一件迷人的事情吗？事实上，《角斗士》这部电影完美地捕捉到了这一点，那就是我们既被奇观所震撼，又被兴奋所激动。
It's the ultimate sporting spectacle, I suppose. But at the same time, there's always that enormous uneasiness that this is an arena in which people fought and died for the entertainment of others. Well, of course, I mean, that's the difference, isn't it, between the film and what originally happened is that we don't really have to worry about that. I don't think many people watch Gladiator and feel squeamish or moral anxiety about it. But of course, when you come to look at that the Colosseum historically has played as an emblem of Rome itself and of ancient Rome. I think it's entirely appropriate that the Colosseum should be the emblem of Rome because it is simultaneously stupefying, awe-inspiring, fascinating, but also kind of terrifying into our way of thinking morally unsettling, which I think Roman civilization was all those things. Yeah. It's a symbol of simultaneously of cruelty and grandeur, isn't it?
我想这是终极的体育奇观。但与此同时，总有一种巨大的不安感，因为这是一个人们为了他人的娱乐而战斗并死去的地方。嗯，当然，我的意思是，这就是电影与真实历史事件的区别，我们不必为此感到担忧。我不认为很多人看《角斗士》时会感到恶心或产生道德焦虑。但当然，当你从历史上看斗兽场作为罗马本身和古罗马的象征时，我认为斗兽场作为罗马的象征是完全恰当的，因为它既令人目瞪口呆、心生敬畏、引人入胜，同时也以我们的思维方式来看，在道德上令人不安，我认为罗马文明就是所有这些东西。是的。它同时是残酷和宏伟的象征，不是吗？
But remember we did the podcast with Mary Beard about classics and the study of the classical world. And she said something that I always remember about when we were talking about the Roman enthusiasm for violence and for gladiatorial games, that we are actually no different because all those tourists who go to see the coliseum you know thousands upon thousands of them every single day it's not just the spectacle of the building no that is drawing them it is also the the dark and savage glamour of the violence at its heart but um so to go back to the Colosseum as an icon of Rome, Tom,
但还记得我们和玛丽·比尔德（Mary Beard）做的关于古典学和古典世界研究的播客吗？她说了一些我一直记得的话，当时我们在谈论罗马人对暴力和角斗比赛的热情，她说我们其实没什么不同，因为那些每天成千上万去参观斗兽场的游客，吸引他们的不仅仅是建筑的奇观，还有其核心暴力所带来的黑暗而野蛮的魅力。但是，嗯，回到斗兽场作为罗马的标志，汤姆，
I mean, it's probably, if you're picking a picture to illustrate the Roman Empire, it's the one you always go to, isn't it? It's the single most obvious emblem of Rome. And it has been for a very long time. So Byron, in his poem Child Harold, wrote, While stands the Colosseum, Rome shall stand. When falls the Colosseum, Rome shall stand. When falls the
我的意思是，如果你要选一张照片来展示罗马帝国，那总是你会选的那一张，不是吗？它是罗马最显而易见的标志。而且很长一段时间以来都是如此。所以拜伦在他的诗《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中写道：“斗兽场屹立，罗马便屹立。斗兽场倒塌，罗马便倒塌。”
Colosseum, Rome shall fall. And when Rome falls, the world. And Byron attributed that to Bede, the Anglo-Saxon monk, probably inaccurately. But it's always been at the heart of Rome. And so the way that it's kind of evolved over the course of its history reflects the patterns of Roman history. So once it ceased being used as an arena, it becomes a cemetery, then it becomes a fortress. Actually, a fortress owned by the Frankapani, who are the ultimate ancestors of Peter Frankapan. Oh, really? Who appeared on our episode about climate change. Yes. It was fleetingly a workhouse for repentant prostitutes under the Renaissance popes.
“当斗兽场倒塌，罗马便会倒塌。当罗马倒塌，世界也会随之倒塌。”拜伦把这句话归于盎格鲁-撒克逊僧侣比德（Bede），这可能是不准确的。但它一直处于罗马的核心。所以它在历史进程中的演变方式反映了罗马历史的模式。一旦它不再被用作竞技场，它就变成了墓地，然后变成了堡垒。实际上，是一个由弗兰吉帕尼家族拥有的堡垒，他们是彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan）的远祖。哦，真的吗？他曾出现在我们关于气候变化的节目中。是的。在文艺复兴时期的教皇统治下，它曾短暂地成为悔罪妓女的收容所。
It became a shrine to the Christians who supposedly were martyred there, even though there's absolutely no evidence that any Christians were martyred there at all. And now, of course, as you say, it's a tourist attraction. And as Mary said in that episode, the hint of blood in the air is absolutely a part of the appeal. So there's a lot of mythology about the Colosseum, Tom. So the Christians are not being fed to lions in the middle of the Colosseum. Well, they might have been, but we have no record of it. Right. So the Byron thing, the Byron poem, that's not right either, is that the idea that-
它成为了据称在那里殉道的基督徒的神殿，尽管完全没有证据表明有任何基督徒在那里殉道。当然，现在正如你所说，它是一个旅游景点。正如玛丽在那一集中所说，空气中弥漫的血腥味绝对是其吸引力的一部分。所以关于斗兽场有很多神话，汤姆。所以基督徒并没有在斗兽场中间被喂给狮子。嗯，他们可能被喂过，但我们没有记录。对。所以拜伦的那件事，拜伦的诗，那也不对，是那种想法——
No, because the original saying, which may or may not have come from Bede, but it's definitely Anglo-Saxon, is referring to the Colossus, which is the great statue built by Nero, which we will come to when we talk about how the Colosseum comes to be built. So there's that. And also, of course, the Romans didn't call it the Colosseum. So this is a stunning revelation to me. The Colosseum is not even his name. No. So people who listened to our episode on the eruption of Vesuvius that we did, the brilliantly named Roman apocalypse. We mentioned Marshall, the epigramist. Marshall wrote a whole series of poems about the inauguration of what we
不，因为最初的说法，可能来自比德，也可能不是，但它绝对是盎格鲁-撒克逊的，指的是“巨像”（Colossus），也就是尼禄建造的巨大雕像，当我们谈到斗兽场是如何建成时，我们会提到它。所以有这个。而且，当然，罗马人并不称它为“斗兽场”（Colosseum）。这对我来说是一个惊人的启示。斗兽场甚至不是它的名字。不。所以听过我们关于维苏威火山爆发那一集（我们称之为“罗马启示录”）的听众，我们提到了讽刺诗人马提雅尔（Martial）。马提雅尔写了一系列关于我们
call the Colosseum. In that, he calls it the Amphitheatrum Caesareum, so Caesar's amphitheater. We also know it as the Flavian amphitheater because it was built by the Flavian dynasty, which was Vespasian and his son Titus, who was emperor during the destruction of Pompeii. So we'll talk about them as well. And this inauguration is presided over by Titus. And the reasons why it comes to be built, I think that there are multiple ways of approaching it to do with aspects that are fundamental to Roman culture,
所称的斗兽场的落成典礼的诗。在诗中，他称之为“凯撒圆形剧场”（Amphitheatrum Caesareum）。我们也称它为“弗拉维圆形剧场”，因为它是由弗拉维王朝建造的，即韦斯巴芗和他的儿子提图斯，提图斯在庞贝毁灭时是皇帝。所以我们也会谈到他们。这次落成典礼由提图斯主持。我认为探讨它建造原因的方法有很多，涉及罗马文化的基本方面，
aspects that are due to the circumstances in which the Flavian dynasty have come to power, and aspects that are due to the specific circumstances of Titus' own reign. I thought that that would be a good way to structure the analysis of how this extraordinary building comes to be. It was absolutely understood to be. And it was absolutely understood to be extraordinary when it was built. So Marshall, in one of his poems, he compares it to all the great wonders of the world. And he says that none of these wonders can compare with this astonishing amphitheater. Fame shall speak of one marvel in place of all. And I think he was right. I mean, I think in a way, the Colosseum is up there with the Great Pyramid as one of the stupefying emblems in the popular
涉及弗拉维王朝掌权的环境，以及提图斯本人统治的具体情况。我认为这将是分析这座非凡建筑如何诞生的好方法。它绝对被认为是不同寻常的。当它建成时，它绝对被认为是不同寻常的。所以马提雅尔在其中一首诗中，将它与世界所有伟大的奇迹进行了比较。他说，这些奇迹中没有一个能与这座令人惊叹的圆形剧场相比。名声将传颂这一奇迹，取代所有其他奇迹。我想他是对的。我的意思是，我认为在某种程度上，斗兽场与大金字塔一样，是大众想象中古代最令人目瞪口呆的标志之一。在谈到斗兽场本身之前，我的意思是，让我们谈谈在它里面发生的事情，也就是角斗比赛。虽然，多米尼克，不仅仅是角斗比赛，我们稍后会谈到，但最著名的是角斗比赛。所以罗马人一直对角斗比赛充满热情，不是吗？这在古代世界是不寻常的吗？是的。我的意思是，我认为这是意大利特有的，但在罗马，它们似乎起源于一种葬礼仪式，向逝者的灵魂献上武装暴力的祭品。它们在广场（Forum）举行，那是帕拉蒂尼山和卡比托利欧山之间巨大的中央开放空间。这些仪式似乎起源于那不勒斯湾沿岸。也就是几个世纪后维苏威火山爆发的地方。这种认为它是一种宗教仪式的想法，我认为对于
imagination of antiquity. Before we get to the Colosseum itself, I mean, let's talk about what happens within it, which is gladiatorial games. Although, Dominic, not just gladiatorial games, but we'll come to that, but most famously, gladiatorial games. So the Romans have always been enthusiasts for gladiatorial games, haven't they? And is that unusual in the ancient world? Yes. I mean, it's distinctively Italian, I think, but in Rome, they seem to have begun as kind of funerary rites, offering a tribute of armed violence to the shades of the departed. And they are staged in the Forum, which is the great central open space between the Palatine and the Capitoline Hills. And these rituals actually seem to have originated along the Bay of Naples. So the very place where Vesuvius erupted centuries later. And this idea that it is a kind of religious rite is very, very important, I think, to
理解角斗对罗马想象力的影响非常非常重要。尽管最初的角色逐渐被娱乐所取代，但总有一种感觉，它应该适当地具有某种崇拜角色。见证这一点的是一位基督教作家特图里亚努斯（Tertullian），他大约在公元200年左右在迦太基写作。他写道，在时间的迷雾中，因为罗马人相信死者的灵魂可以通过流淌人血来安抚，他们过去常通过屠杀俘虏或专门为此廉价购买的奴隶来纪念葬礼。
understanding the power that gladiatorial combat has on the Roman imagination. Even though that initial role comes to be subsumed with entertainment, there is always a sense that it should properly have a kind of cultic role. So witness to this is by a Christian writer, Tertullian, who's writing in Carthage around AD 200. He's writing, back in the mists of time, because the Romans believed that the souls of the dead could be propitiated by the spilling of human blood, they used to mark funerals by slaughtering captives or slaves bought cheaply, especially for that purpose.
渐渐地，人们开始觉得通过将其转化为一种乐趣来掩盖这种不虔诚是个好主意。于是，罗马人在公开谋杀中找到了对死亡的慰藉。”现在，特图里亚努斯当然是以基督徒的身份写作的，所以他本质上是一个敌对的见证人。但我认为他准确地捕捉到了罗马人对角斗比赛态度中存在的东西，即对它应该仅仅作为娱乐而存在的一种不安。这种感觉是，这些仪式是一种神圣的仪式，罗马人称这些为“munera”，但它们逐渐变成了罗马人所称的“spectacula”，显然我们现在的词“spectacle”（奇观）就是由此而来，即供人观看的事物。
Gradually, it began to seem a good idea to mask the impiety of this by transforming it into a pleasure. So it was that the Romans found comfort for death in open murder." Now, Tertullian is, of course, writing as a Christian, so he is inherently a hostile witness. But I think that he is accurately fixing on something that is there in the Roman attitudes towards gladiatorial combat, which is a certain nervousness about the idea that it should rank as mere entertainment. The sense that these rituals are kind of sacral rites, the Romans call these munera, but they come to be what the Romans call spectacular, from which we get obviously our word spectacle, things to be watched.
所以贯穿整个罗马历史，即使在那种认为人们是为了安抚死者灵魂而战斗的感觉开始消退之后，他们仍然必须为它找到正当理由，说它不仅仅是娱乐，它必须不仅仅是那样。基本上，随着我们进入共和国的最后几个世纪，随着罗马成为一个大国，随着城市扩张，随着罗马人的身份认同成为整个意大利的共同身份，角斗比赛被作为维持社会凝聚力、维持公民罗马身份感的一种手段，因为观看它们的权利是公民身份的主要福利之一。
And so right the way through Roman history, even after that sense that the men are fighting to appease the souls of the dead starts to fade, they still have to find justifications for it to say, it's not just entertainment, it has to be something more than that. And basically, as we move into the latter centuries of the Republic, as Rome is becoming a great power, as the city is expanding, as the identity of Roman is becoming one that is standing across the whole of Italy, gladiatorial combat is offered as a means of maintaining social cohesion, of maintaining a sense of civic Roman identity, because the right to watch them is one of the key perks of citizenship.
所以坐下来观看角斗比赛意味着你是罗马人，意味着你在分享一种共同的经历。虽然你说坐着，但我认为人们通常被要求站着，对吗？你说得完全正确。那是一个口误。是的。所以这是一件非凡的事情，在共和国时期，罗马的道德家们对人们可能坐着观看奇观的想法感到偏执。以至于拉丁语中表示座位的词是“seditio”，我们现在的词“sedition”（煽动叛乱）就是由此而来。对于罗马人来说，它开始象征内乱、无政府状态，所有那些因未能维持适当的社会凝聚力和道德标准而产生的事情，所以“sedition”，我不知道，这太迷人了。
So to sit and watch a gladiatorial combat means you are a Roman, means you are sharing in a common experience. Although you say sit, but am I not right in thinking that often you're expected to stand? You are absolutely right. That was a slip. Yes. So this is the extraordinary thing, is that under the Republic, Roman moralists are paranoid about the idea that people might sit to watch the spectacular. To the extent that the Latin word for seating is seditio, from which we get our word sedition. For the Romans, it comes to signify civil strife, anarchy, all the things that come from a failure to maintain the proper social cohesion and the sense of moral standards so sedition i did not know that that's fascinating
而且汤姆，你知道吗，这里有一个有趣的共鸣，因为在英国，在喜欢足球的人群中，有一种轻微的感觉，你知道，如果你是一个真正的球迷，你应该站着。你应该站着。而且坐着是罗伊·基恩（Roy Keane）所说的“虾仁鸡尾酒三明治旅”的专利。是的。他们去那里，并不是以真正的比赛精神去观看，因为成为一个真正的球迷就是当有人在后面向你的腿上撒尿时，你依然站着。
and tom you know what there's a funny uh resonance here because in england among people who like football there is a slight yeah sense that uh you know if you're a real fan, you should stand. You should stand. And that the sitting is for what Roy Keane famously called the kind of prawn cocktail sandwich brigade. Yes. Who are going, they're not going in the true spirit of the game because to be a true fan is to stand while someone is urinating on your leg from behind.
在20世纪70年代的看台足球迷风格中，我的意思是，这确实是一个非常有趣的平行，因为全座席体育场是在一系列骚乱、灾难和大规模死亡事件之后引入的，不是吗？是的，我认为有一种，嗯，你比我更像个球迷，但我感觉到在那些铁杆球迷中有一种轻微的感觉，认为它变得软弱了。我同意这一点。是的。不仅仅是座位只是给有钱人准备的，而是任何坐下的人都在某种程度上背叛了那种应该成为球迷标志的强硬。嗯，近年来有一个非常响亮的运动，他们称之为
And in the sort of 1970s terraces football fan style i mean it is a really interesting parallel because the the all-seater stadiums were brought in weren't they after a series of kind of riots and disasters and mass deaths and things yeah and i think there is a kind of well you're much more of a fan than me but i get the sense that there is this slight feeling among the kind of the really hardcore fans that it's gone soft. I would agree with that. Yeah. It's not just that the seats are just for rich people, but that anyone who sits down is kind of portraying the toughness that should probably be the mark of a fan. Well, there's been a very vocal movement in recent years for what they call
“安全站立”，要求恢复站立，因为站立更符合比赛精神。它更阳刚。它更坚韧。它更真实。它更无产阶级，所有这些东西。嗯，参议院，罗马参议院绝对会同意你的观点，因为在公元前二世纪中期，他们引入了立法以确保人们必须站着。这样做的理由是，在站立中，罗马种族的适当阳刚之气应该与放松联系起来。换句话说，即使在享受乐趣时，罗马人也在肯定他们阳刚的性格。天哪。好吧。
safe standing, to bring back standing because standing is more, it's truer to the spirit of the game. It's more masculine. It's more hardy. It's more authentic. It's more proletarian, all these things. Well, the Senate, the Roman Senate would absolutely have agreed with you because in the middle of the second century BC, they brought in legislation to ensure that people had to stand. And the justification for this was that in standing, the proper virility of the Roman race should be linked to relaxation. So in other words, even while they're enjoying themselves, the Romans are affirming their virile character. Crikey. Okay.
所以这非常罗伊·基恩，不是吗？是的，非常罗伊·基恩。所以这是罗马人证明举办角斗娱乐活动的一种方式，无论是“munera”还是“spectacula”。另一个原因是，随着帝国的扩张，随着战争的经验从罗马本身的边界转移到海外遥远的边疆，人们感到有必要提醒罗马城内的大众，是什么支撑了罗马的伟大。角斗士在出去战斗前宣誓的誓言，是以
So that's very Roy Keane, isn't it? Yeah, very Roy Keane. So that is one way in which the Romans justify staging gladiatorial entertainments, whether they're munera or spectacular. The other one is that as the empire expands, and as the experience of warfare moves from the limits of Rome itself to distant frontiers overseas, there is a feeling that there is a need to remind the mass of the Roman people in the city itself of what it is that underpins Roman greatness. The oath that gladiators swear before they go out and fight is modeled on the oath that
罗马军团士兵宣誓的誓言为蓝本的。在公民士兵和为大众娱乐而战的奴隶之间存在着一种等同关系。所以角斗士的誓言是：“我将忍受被烧、被绑、被鞭打，并被剑杀死。”这是对在罗马军队服役所需条件的基本上的一种放大。所以你可以站着观看战斗并感到，是的，这是对支撑罗马伟大的一切的展示。关于角斗士，在我们继续之前有一个简短的问题。角斗士本身，你说奴隶。他们是奴隶，对吗？你不是出于选择而成为职业角斗士的。
is sworn by a Roman legionary. There is a kind of equation there between the citizen soldier and the slave who is fighting for the entertainment of the masses. So the gladiatorial oath is, I will endure to be burned, to be bound, to be beaten, and to be killed by the sword. And that is an amplification of basically what it takes to serve in the Roman armies. So you can stand and watch the combat and feel, yeah, this is a display of everything that underpins the greatness of Rome. And just on the gladiators, one quick question before we move on. The gladiators themselves, you said slaves. They are slaves, are they? You're not a professional gladiator out of choice.
不。我的意思是，从长远来看，有臭名昭著的例子，康茂德就是一个例子，上层阶级的人，角斗士的魅力如此之大，以至于那些不是奴隶的人，贵族成员，甚至像康茂德那样的皇帝，都想参与到这种兴奋中来。但他们是奴隶。他们是社会最底层。他们与妓女和演员等社会渣滓并列。所以这就是他们在社会光谱中地位有多低的标准。我认为我们应该回到对演员的那种态度。我知道我们有一些演员在听这个播客，他们会关掉的。所以因为他们是奴隶，他们可以被买卖。显然你拥有的钱越多，你
No. I mean, in the long run, there are notoriously, Commodus being an example, upper-class people, the glamour of the gladiator is such that the people who aren't slaves, members of the nobility, even an emperor in the form of Commodus wants to partake in the excitement of this. But they are slaves. They are the lowest of the low. They are ranked alongside such dregs of society as prostitutes and actors. So that is the measure of just how lowly they rank in the social spectrum. I think we should get back to that attitude about actors. I know we have a few actors who listen to this podcast, they'll switch off. So because they're slaves, they can be bought. And obviously the more money you have, the more
买的就越多，你能展示的规模就越大。随着我们进入共和国的最后一个世纪，越来越多的军阀主导了共和国的运作，因此人们对大人物利用角斗比赛来提升形象、收获选票的焦虑也在加剧。所以不出所料，是凯撒开辟了这条道路。所以在他成为执政官之前，当他还在努力奋斗时，他的父亲去世了，他抓住这个机会真正地大出风头。所以这被定为“Munera”。这是关于安抚凯撒父亲的灵魂。他弄到了320对角斗士，这是迄今为止在一次活动中
you can buy and the bigger display you can put on. And as we enter the final century of the Republic and you have ever more warlords dominating the functioning of the Republic, so you get an acceleration of anxiety about great men using gladiatorial combat to promote their image to harvest votes. So unsurprisingly, it's Caesar who kind of blazes the path. So before he becomes consul, while he's still kind of trying to make his way, his father dies and he seizes this as an opportunity to really kind of cut a dash. So this is cast as Munera. This is about appeasing the soul of Caesar's father. And he gets 320 pairs of gladiators, by far the largest number that had ever been
战斗过的最大数量，他给他们穿上了银色的盔甲。这完全是一场奇观。在此之后，参议院引入了立法，试图限制这种奢侈行为。同样，为了进行足球类比，类比非常清楚。这相当于像西尔维奥·贝卢斯科尼（Silvio Berlusconi）利用足球。AC米兰。我想现在那些敌对的中东独裁者购买足球队的方式也是如此。是的。你知道，曼城或纽卡斯尔联队之类的。
fought in one occasion, and he dresses them in silver armour. This is a complete spectacle. The Senate, in the wake of this, introduced legislation to try and rein in extravagance like this. Again, to draw the football parallel, the analogy is pretty clear. This is equivalent to someone like Silvia Berlusconi using football. AC Milan. And I guess the way that kind of rival Middle Eastern despots now are buying football teams. Yeah. You know, so Manchester City or Newcastle United or whatever.
是的，巴黎圣日耳曼。是的，绝对是。我想体育是地缘政治竞争的工具。是的。而且我认为这在罗马城市结构中表现得最有趣的方式是，没有永久性的体育场供人们去观看角斗士。所以你在其他地方确实能看到它们。描述它的词“amphitheatrum”来自希腊语。所以基本上，它意味着一个可以从两边观看的空间，而不是像剧院那样是半圆形的。但它是一种独特的意大利
Yeah, Paris Saint-Germain. Yeah, absolutely. Sport as a vehicle for geopolitical rivalry, I suppose. Yeah. And I think that the most intriguing way in which this is manifest in the urban fabric of Rome is that there is no permanent stadium where people can go and watch gladiators. So you do get them elsewhere. The word that describes it, amphitheatrum, comes from Greek. So basically, it means a space that can be viewed from both sides, as opposed to a theatre where you're in a semicircle. But it is a distinctively Italian
形式。所以你问到角斗士，他们是意大利人。而演变来举办这些展示的圆形剧场，不仅是意大利的，而且在国际上成为了“罗马性”（Romanitas）的标志。如果你看到一个圆形剧场，你就知道你在一个罗马城市，但你在罗马没有永久性的圆形剧场。相反，在广场或罗马郊外的战神广场上建造的建筑的虚构性是乐趣的一部分。这是雄心勃勃的贵族们花钱的地方的一部分，所以当你去看角斗士时，你也会去看一场建筑盛宴。这仍然是
form. So you asked about gladiators, they're Italian. And the amphitheatre, which evolves to stage these displays, is also not just Italian, but becomes internationally the marker of Romanitas. If you see an amphitheatre, you know you're in a Roman city, but you don't get a permanent amphitheater in Rome. Instead, the artificiality of the structures that are built either in the Forum or on the Campus Martius on the outskirts of Rome are part of the fun. This is part of what ambitious noblemen are spending their money on, so that when you go to see gladiators, you will also be going to see an architectural extravaganza. And this remains a source of
共和国时期持续紧张的根源。但一旦奥古斯都掌权并建立独裁统治，这种情况当然就开始缓解了。而且我认为非常能说明问题的是，只有在奥古斯都夺取政权后，你才在罗马得到了第一个永久性的圆形剧场，有趣的是，它不是由奥古斯都建造的，而是由他的副手之一建造的。但奥古斯都继续建造他自己那种奇观和角斗士展示舞台，他以绝对前所未有的规模举办这些活动。所以凯撒通过投入，是多少，320名角斗士而引起了人们的侧目。奥古斯都举办了一场有10,000名角斗士参加的表演。
constant tension under the Republic. But that of course starts to ease once Augustus comes to power and establishes an autocracy. And I think it's really telling that it's only once Augustus has seized power that you get the first permanent amphitheater in Rome, not built by Augustus, interestingly, but by one of his lieutenants. But Augustus continues to build his own kind of spectacles and stages for the display of gladiators, which he puts on in an absolutely unprecedented scale. So Caesar had kind of raised eyebrows by putting on, what was it, 320 gladiators. Augustus stages a show that features 10,000 gladiators.
我的意思是，这听起来，A，是一个令人怀疑的整数，但也像典型的罗马式夸张。他可能只有500人左右，这更合理吗？可能吧。我的意思是，这很多。我的意思是，10,000在拉丁语中是“很多”的意思。多到你数不清。而且我怀疑奥古斯都本人说是10,000，因为这是苏维托尼乌斯（Suetonius）引用的，他可以查阅奥古斯都的记录。这就像唐纳德·特朗普的就职典礼，汤姆。是的，这是有史以来规模最大的。这是有史以来规模最大的展示。没错。所以在那一点上，去观看比赛的体验。
I mean, that does sound, A, a suspiciously round figure, but also like classic Roman exaggeration. Is it more plausible that he may be at 500 or something? Possibly. I mean, it's a lot. I mean, 10,000 is Latin for a lot. So many, you can't count them. And I suspect that Augustus himself says it's 10,000 because this is quoted by Suetonius, who has access to Augustus' records. It's like Donald Trump's inauguration, Tom. Yeah, it was the biggest ever. It was the biggest display ever. Exactly. So at that point, the experience of going to watch the games.
所以在奥古斯都统治下，它变得更有序了。是这样吗？更受管制，更结构化，更阶级分层等等。没错。所以这种认为角斗士的展示在某种程度上揭示了罗马人民道德品质的想法，并没有随着共和国的结束而消亡。事实上，它变得更加强烈，因为奥古斯都可以控制这些奇观。每个人都知道这反映了他对罗马的愿景。到这个时候，观众已经坐着了。但奥古斯都非常非常担心人们只是随意地坐着，他们只是挤进去，想坐哪就坐哪。他觉得吃虾仁鸡尾酒的阶层，参议员们，应该有最好的座位，而且他们应该被看到拥有最好的座位。而那些缺乏必要财产资格的人应该被挤到上面去。而且这应该反映出罗马人民组织方式的
So under Augustus, it's becoming more ordered. Is that right? More regimented, more structured, more class stratified and so on. Right. So this idea that the display of gladiators is somehow revealing something about the moral character of the Roman people, it doesn't die with the ending of the Republic. In fact, it becomes intensified because Augustus can control the spectacles. Everyone knows that it reflects his vision of Rome. By this point, spectators are sitting. But Augustus is very, very anxious about the fact that people are just kind of sitting willy-nilly, that they're just kind of crowding in, sitting wherever they want. He feels that the cocktail eating classes, the senators, should have the best seats and they should be seen to have the best seats. And that people who lack the necessary property qualifications should be shoved up at the top. And that this should reflect the order and dignity
秩序和尊严。因为罗马人痴迷于社会分层。他们有一种叫做“人口普查”（census）的东西，这不仅仅是关于统计有多少罗马人，而是关于他们的财产资格是什么，他们的道德地位是什么。你可以以极其细致的严谨性确定你的社会地位。奥古斯都非常热衷于此，他觉得角斗展示应该做到这一点，观众坐的地方应该是一场“石头上的人口普查”，如果你愿意的话。他觉得角斗展示应该是一场“活的人口普查”，人们去那里，他们确切地知道他们应该在哪里。但也有，
of the way that the Roman people are organized. Because the Romans are obsessed by social stratification. They have this thing called the census, which isn't just about counting how many Romans there are, but what their property qualifications are, what their moral standing is. You can pinpoint your social standing with minute punctiliousness. Augustus is very keen on this, and he feels that gladiatorial displays should do that, that the place that the spectators are sitting should be a census in stone, if you like. He feels that a gladiatorial display should be a lived census, that people go there and they know exactly where they should be. But there is also,
我认为，罗马独裁统治中非常非常独特的东西。在任何其他古代独裁统治中，我想不出有什么真正可比的东西，那就是皇帝通过举办这些展示，在某种程度上是在拿自己的声誉冒险。这些展示必须有效。它们必须令人印象深刻。他必须对自己在大众中的受欢迎程度充满信心，因为他是一个公众人物，如果他被嘘，那将是可怕的。所以这就是《角斗士》中那种动态的一部分。哦，绝对是。是的。是的。人们是会站在康茂德一边还是站在罗素·克劳一边的问题，是构建整个情节的关键动态。而且这绝对符合那种
I think, something that is very, very unique to the Roman autocracy. There's nothing really comparable that I can think of in any other ancient autocracy, which is that the emperor, by staging these displays, is kind of putting his reputation on the line. These displays have to be effective. They have to be impressive. He has to be confident in his popularity with the masses because he is a public figure and it would be terrible for him to be booed, for instance. So that's part of the dynamic that you get in Gladiator. Oh, absolutely you do. Yeah. Yeah. The question of, are people going to be siding with Commodus or with Russell Crowe is the key dynamic that structures the entire plot. And that is absolutely true to the jeopardy
总是笼罩着举办奇观的皇帝的危险。那些奇观，贯穿了早期的皇帝，不是吗？朱里亚-克劳狄王朝。所以你这里有克劳狄的例子。克劳狄，他根本不是一个尚武的人，对吧？他是一个学者型的人。他利用这个作为舞台来假装他是一个尚武的人。这公平吗？是的。所以是克劳狄得到了那句著名的敬礼，“皇帝万岁，我们这些即将死去的人向你致敬”。所以这是苏维托尼乌斯记录的。但同样，迷人的是，这并不是在一个圆形剧场里。而是在一个他即将排干水的湖里。在它被排干之前，他决定举办一场
that is always kind of shadowing an emperor who's putting on spectacular. Those spectacles, they run right through the early emperors, don't they? The Julio-Claudians. So you've got the example here of Claudius. Claudius, who is not a martial man at all, actually, is he? He's a scholarly man. He uses this as a stage on which to pretend he's a martial man. Is that fair? Yeah. So it's Claudius who gets the famous salute, hail emperor, we who are about to die, salute you. So this is recorded by Suetonius. But again, what's fascinating about it is that this is not in an amphitheater. It's in a lake that he is about to drain. And before it gets drained, he decides that he's going to hold a
海军奇观，所有人群都聚集在岸边。当角斗士说这个时，“我们这些即将死去的人向你致敬”。他回答说，嗯，但你们可能不会死。这很令人安心。所以所有的角斗士都说，太棒了。于是他们放下了所有的武器，假设他已经赦免了他们。克劳狄大发雷霆。他说，不，我没有。而角斗士拒绝战斗。克劳狄不得不从座位上站起来，一瘸一拐地走下去，训斥他们，让他们战斗。这就是一个皇帝搞砸了一场展示所面临的潜在陷阱的例子。那不太好莱坞，对吧？不，那一点也不好莱坞。所以这种混乱既显示了皇帝面临的危险。你必须确保奇观是正确的。而且它也显示了你仍然没有在罗马拥有一个永久性的圆形剧场，
kind of naval spectacle and all the crowds kind of gather around the banks. And when the gladiators say this, we who are about to die, salute you. And he answers, well, but you may not die. That's reassuring. And so all the gladiators go, brilliant. And so they down all their weapons on the assumption that he has offered them a pardon. And Claudius is furious. He said, no, I haven't. And the gladiators are refusing to fight. And Claudius has to get up from his seat and kind of hobble down and harangue them and get them to fight. And that is an example of the potential pitfalls that face an emperor who screws up a display. That's not so Hollywood, is it? No, that's not so Hollywood at all. So this kind of shambles shows both the perils that face an emperor. You've got to make sure that the spectacle is right. And it also shows that you still don't have a permanent amphitheater in Rome,
世界女王，帝国的首都。到这个时候，任何有志于成为重要城市空间的城市都有一个圆形剧场。罗马没有。我想我们应该在这里休息一下，你觉得呢？是的，我想我们应该在这里休息一下，我们将带着斗兽场的建造、斗兽场的奇观回来，罗马没有。我想我们应该在这里休息一下，你觉得呢？是的，我想我们应该在这里休息一下。我们将带着斗兽场的建造、斗兽场的奇观、它所有的政治和文化意义回来。我们将在休息后这样做。
the queen of the world, the capital of the empire. Every other city with any pretensions to be a significant urban space by this point does have an amphitheater. Rome doesn't. And I think we should take a break here, do you think? Yes, I think we should take a break here and we will return with the building of the Colosseum, the spectacle of the Colosseum, Rome doesn't. And I think we should take a break here, do you think? Yes, I think we should take a break here. And we will return with the building of the Colosseum, the spectacle of the Colosseum, all its political and cultural meanings. And we'll do that after the break.
到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开了娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在谈论斗兽场。汤姆，你非常失职，因为你没有提到你在你的新书《Pax》中非常精彩地写到了这一点。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about the Colosseum. Tom, you've been very remiss because you've not mentioned that you've written about this quite brilliantly in your new book, Pax.
哦，多米尼克。读者们，听众们以前从未听过我们在播客中提到过。所以这对他们来说将是一个新鲜事，听到你出了这本新书《Pax》。它是关于罗马黄金时代的战争与和平，对吧？罗马帝国鼎盛时期的生与死。你的书《Pax》全是关于弗拉维王朝的。所以现在我们有了这些人，他们是暴发户。他们在尼禄死后的混乱之后夺取了权力。所以是韦斯巴芗和他的儿子提图斯。所以为什么这标志着一个变化
Oh, Dominic. That readers, that listeners will never have heard us mention before on this podcast. So this will be a novelty for them to hear that you've got this new book out, Pax. It's about war and peace in Rome's golden age, isn't it? Life and death at the high point of the Roman empire. Your book, Pax, is all about the Flavian dynasty. And so now we have these people who have, they're upstarts. They have taken power after the chaos that follows the death of Nero. So it's Vespasian and his son Titus. So why does this mark a change
在罗马人对角斗比赛以及他们举办比赛的体育场的态度上？嗯，我认为他们不是来自精英背景。因此，他们可能受到的朱里亚-克劳狄皇帝所受的假设和偏见的影响较小。所以他们可以跳出框框思考，也许程度更大。但还有一个非常明显的需要，即在城市的城市结构上打上他们的权力、他们的权威、他们王朝存在的烙印。尼禄，朱里亚-克劳狄王朝的最后一位皇帝，在类似的光线下所做的事情给了他们这样做的机会。尼禄在大火期间是皇帝。
in the Roman attitude towards gladiatorial games and the stadia in which they staged them? Well, I think that they're not from an elite background. And so as a result, they are probably less tied to the assumptions and prejudices that had governed the Julia-Claudian emperors. So they can kind of think out of the box, perhaps to a greater degree. But there is also a very obvious need to stamp their power, their authority, the existence of their dynasty on the urban fabric of the city. They're given the opportunity to do that by what Nero, the last of the Julia Claudian emperors, had done in a similar light. Nero had been emperor during the Great Fire.
我们做了一期关于他的节目。在大火之后，他清理了所有的瓦砾，建造了这个巨大的享乐宫殿，其特色是一座镶嵌着黄金的房子，所以在阳光下闪闪发光。他有计划建造一座巨大的巨像，上面有他自己的脸，还有一个周围环绕着游乐花园的湖泊。这被参议院精英视为一种绝对的自我放纵的展示，这显然是，但这忽略了一个事实，即这些公园可能对大众开放。关于这一点，关键在于没有对大众开放。关于这一点，关键在于在游乐花园里没有社会秩序。人们可以随意漫步。所以当韦斯巴芗掌权时，他有每一个机会摆脱这个尼禄的纪念碑。韦斯巴芗的全部噱头是，他是一个粗犷、务实、老派、吃苦耐劳的士兵，没有时间去管游乐花园和黄金屋。
We did an episode on him. In the wake of the Great Fire, he clears away all the rubble and builds this enormous pleasure palace that features a house cheesed with gold so it glints in the sun. He's got plans for an enormous colossus giant statue with his own face and a lake with pleasure gardens all around it. This is cast by the senatorial elite as being an absolute display of self-indulgence, which it clearly is, but that ignores the fact that probably these parks are open to the mass of the people. The key thing about that is that there's no to the mass of the people. And the key thing about that is that there's no social ordering in a pleasure garden. People can just wander in willy-nilly. So when Vespasian comes to power, he has every opportunity to get rid of this monument to Nero. Vespasian's whole shtick is that he's a kind of rugged, no-nonsense, old-fashioned, turn-it-munching soldier with no time for pleasure gardens and golden houses.
所以他开始了拆除过程。他把所有的雕像和艺术品从尼禄的房子里搬出来，放在他建在奥古斯都广场旁边的和平神庙里。他用混凝土填满了湖泊。然后有一个问题，嗯，我们该怎么处理这个世界上最宝贵的房地产中这片巨大的空地？它是空的。我们可以做任何我们想做的事。这就是他想到我们应该有一个圆形剧场的想法的地方。它的规模必须足够令人目瞪口呆，以至于它基本上可以容纳罗马人民的大众。我的意思是，它不能容纳所有人，因为罗马有大约一百万人，但它必须足够大，以至于它可以充分象征居住在城市中的整个
And so he starts the process of demolition. He moves all the statues and works of art out from Nero's house, puts it in a temple to peace that he has built next to Augustus' Forum. He fills the lake with concrete. Then there is a question, well, what do we do with this vast empty space in what is probably the most valuable piece of real estate in the world? It's empty. We can do anything we want. This is where he gets the idea we should have an amphitheater. It's got to be on a scale that is sufficiently stupefying that it can basically seat the mass of the Roman people. I mean, it can't see all of them because there's about a million people in Rome, but it's got to be large enough that it can adequately symbolize the presence of the entire
大众的存在。虽然有一个因素，因为尼禄正在建造一个游乐花园，当然尼禄，正如你在你的播客中精彩描述的那样，当你做尼禄时，你把他重塑为这个民粹主义者、表演者等等，是否有一个因素是他们必须做一些，A，非常炫耀的事情，B，那是，民主是错误的词，但你知道我的意思，那是对人民开放的，而不是为参议院精英准备的华丽新街区之类的。是的，这是一个宣言。嗯，它同时在做两件事。它既想吃蛋糕又想拥有它，因为一方面，它在说，我们不会有任何关于享乐湖的胡闹。这是好的老式罗马娱乐。它将是道德的。它将是正直的。它将是血腥的展示，这将使人们变得更好。所以它绝对是罗马传统的一部分。另一方面，它在说，看，我们在这里。我们是新王朝。我们负担得起这个，我们把它给你，罗马人民。所以这就是为什么它
mass of people who live in the city. Is there an element though that because Nero was building a pleasure garden, and of course Nero, as you brilliantly described in your podcast, when you did Nero, and you sort of recast him as this populist, showman and stuff, is there an element of them having to do something that is A, very showy, and B, that is, democratic is the wrong word, but you know what I mean, that is open to the people rather than fancy new blocks for the senatorial elite or something. Yeah, it's a proclamation. Well, it's doing two things simultaneously. It's having its cake and eating it because on the one hand, it's saying, we're not having any nonsense with Pleasure Lakes. This is good old-fashioned Roman entertainment. It's going to be moral. It's going to be upstanding. It's going to be displays of blood, which will make people better. So it's absolutely part of Roman tradition. And on the other hand, it's saying, look, we are here. We're the new dynasty. We can afford this and we are giving it to you, the Roman people. And so that's why it's
以如此巨大的规模建造。这不仅仅是为了容纳人们。这是为了做出一个非常非常明显的声明。所以凯瑟琳·韦尔奇（Catherine Welch），她写了一本关于圆形剧场从起源到斗兽场的演变的精彩书籍，曾谈到斗兽场，它耸立在罗马城市景观之上，就像大教堂后来耸立在欧洲中世纪城镇之上一样。大教堂告诉你很多关于中世纪人们的价值体系。你拥有这座伟大的体育、奇观和血腥运动的纪念碑这一事实，告诉你很多关于罗马人的价值体系。而且它的奢侈就是重点。而且这是一个非常激进的新设计。
built on the massive scale that it is. It's not just about fitting people in. It's about making a very, very visible statement. So Catherine Welch, who's written a brilliant book on the evolution of the amphitheater from its beginnings up to the Colosseum, has said about the Colosseum that it towered over the Roman cityscape in much the way that cathedrals later towered over medieval towns. Cathedrals tell you a lot about the value systems of people in the Middle Ages. The fact that you have this great monument to sport and spectacle and blood sports tells you a lot about the value system of the Romans. And the extravagance of it is the point. And it's a pretty radical new design.
它建立在如此宏大的规模之上。这不仅仅是为了容纳更多人，更是为了做出一个非常、非常显眼的声明。凯瑟琳·韦尔奇曾写过一本关于圆形剧场从起源到罗马斗兽场演变的精彩著作，她曾评价说，罗马斗兽场在罗马城市景观中高耸入云，正如后来大教堂在中世纪城镇中高耸入云一样。大教堂向你展示了中世纪人们的价值体系。而这座为体育、奇观和血腥运动而建的伟大纪念碑，也向你展示了罗马人的价值体系。它的奢华正是其核心所在，这是一种非常激进的新设计。
So the outside, it has kind of huge statues. It has different kinds of pillars and all kinds of things like that. It has beautiful awnings. It is designed to be spectacular. The further benefit of this for the Flavians is that it enables them to remind people who are going there about the great military triumph of the Flavian dynasty, which is the defeat of the Judeans, and specifically Titus' capture of Jerusalem, which had been stripped of its treasures. These treasures had been paraded through the streets of Rome. Now, this is a sleight of hand because actually there wasn't much treasure in Judea.
所以外观上，它有巨大的雕像。它有各种各样的柱子和诸如此类的东西。它有漂亮的遮阳篷。它的设计旨在引人注目。这对弗拉维王朝来说，更深远的意义在于，它能提醒前往那里的人们记住弗拉维王朝伟大的军事胜利，即对犹太人的征服，特别是提图斯对耶路撒冷的占领，那座城市已经被洗劫一空。这些财宝曾被游行展示在罗马街头。不过，这是一种障眼法，因为实际上犹太并没有多少财宝。
The Flavians are massively exaggerating how much loot they have taken. In fact, the money seems to have come from Vespasian and Titus hugely raising taxes on the eastern half of the empire. But it's all good stuff. A Roman emperor, the word emperor comes from imperator, which literally means general. So it's Vespasian and Titus saying, we are imperatores. We are an imperator in the original sense of the word, not as Nero was, a man who never led an army, who just sat around playing the liar. So it's making a statement about the manliness of the Flavians and the manliness of the Roman people.
弗拉维王朝极大地夸大了他们掠夺的战利品数量。事实上，这些钱似乎来自韦斯巴芗和提图斯对帝国东半部大幅增加的税收。但这都是好事。罗马皇帝，“emperor”这个词源于“imperator”，字面意思是将军。所以这是韦斯巴芗和提图斯在说，我们是统帅。我们是原始意义上的统帅，不像尼禄那样，一个从未领导过军队、整天坐着弹里拉琴的人。所以这宣示了弗拉维家族的阳刚之气，以及罗马人民的阳刚之气。
And just on the Colosseum, the construction of it, we presumably have no idea who designed it, who built it. These things are lost to us, are they? No. I mean, it's often said that it's Judean slaves. It may well have been. A huge harvest of slaves was taken from Judea and they would have provided a ready source of manpower. We know that Vespasian sends a whole troop of Judean slaves to Nero when he's trying to build his canal through the Isthmus of Corinth, which never gets completed because Nero dies.
关于斗兽场的建造，我们大概不知道是谁设计的，是谁建造的。这些信息对我们来说已经失传了，是吗？不。我的意思是，人们常说那是犹太奴隶干的。很可能确实如此。从犹太地区掠夺了大量的奴隶，他们提供了现成的劳动力来源。我们知道，当尼禄试图在科林斯地峡开凿运河时，韦斯巴芗曾派出一整队犹太奴隶去帮忙，但因为尼禄去世，运河最终没能完工。
I think it's pretty clear that Judea is being used as a source of manpower for kind of big infrastructure projects and and a capacity so i've seen different estimates from 50 000 to about 80 000 people i mean extraordinary when you consider the small size of the population compared with today that they are building a stadium of that size but i suppose there's still an element of confusion in that is it not set seats for everybody? I mean, the capacity can change depending on how many people you're choosing to pack in. So this now comes to the specific question of why it matters to Titus.
我认为很明显，犹太地区被用作大型基础设施项目的劳动力来源，我看到过不同的估计，从5万人到8万人不等。考虑到当时的人口规模与今天相比非常小，他们能建造如此规模的体育场，这真是非同寻常。但我认为其中仍存在一些困惑，难道不是每个人都有座位吗？我的意思是，容量可以根据你选择挤进多少人而改变。所以这就引出了一个具体问题：为什么这对提图斯很重要。
Okay. So it's probable that the Colosseum is inaugurated by Titus in the summer of AD 80. Might have been 81, but more likely to be 80. That is a year after the subject of our previous podcast, the destruction of Pompeii and Herculaneum. That is one of a number of disasters that rocks the reign of Titus. Other disasters include a major outbreak of fire that destroys the Pantheon. This is why the Pantheon, the temple to all the gods, will get rebuilt by Hadrian, the great dome building that most tourists to Rome will have seen, the best preserved Roman temple. But it also destroys the
好的。所以斗兽场很可能是在公元80年夏天由提图斯揭幕的。可能是81年，但80年的可能性更大。那是在我们上一期播客的主题——庞贝和赫库兰尼姆毁灭的一年之后。那是困扰提图斯统治的一系列灾难之一。其他灾难包括一场摧毁了万神殿的大火。这就是为什么万神殿，这座供奉所有神灵的庙宇，后来由哈德良重建，也就是大多数罗马游客所见到的那座拥有巨大圆顶、保存最完好的罗马神庙。但它也摧毁了
temple of Jupiter on the capital, which is the most significant sacred space in Rome. It had already burnt down in the year of the Four Emperors when Vespasian comes to power, AD 69. That had absolutely been taken as a terrifying symbol of the wrath of the gods, that that temple had been burnt down. The fact that Vespasian and Titus have been busy repairing it and now it's burnt down again, this is terrible. Then there's an awful plague that ravages Rome. Again, terrible. And then of course you have the eruption of Vesuvius and the cities of Pompeii and Herculaneum were literally entombed. So there are huge numbers of people who have not been given the funerary rites that they should have been. And so the anxiety is that their restless ghosts are going
卡比托利欧山上的朱庇特神庙，那是罗马最重要的神圣空间。在韦斯巴芗掌权的公元69年“四帝之年”，它就已经被烧毁过一次。那次神庙被烧毁绝对被视为神灵愤怒的可怕象征。事实上，韦斯巴芗和提图斯一直忙于修复它，而现在它又被烧毁了，这太可怕了。然后还有一场肆虐罗马的可怕瘟疫。同样，非常可怕。当然，还有维苏威火山的喷发，庞贝和赫库兰尼姆两座城市被彻底掩埋。因此，有大量的人没有得到他们应有的葬礼仪式。所以人们担心他们不安的灵魂会
to roam the world unappeased. And so Titus has a desperate need to appease the spirits of these unburied dead. And I think there is no question when he inaugurates the Colosseum, he is trying to do it not just as a kind of grand master of ceremonies, a man who is offering entertainment to the people, but as someone who is the moral guardian of the empire and of the city. So Titus had actually had quite a bad reputation before he becomes emperor. He'd been guardian of the empire and of the city. Titus had actually had quite a bad reputation before he becomes emperor. He'd been head of the Praetorians, so the imperial bodyguard, and that had given him quite a bad reputation. He'd been a notorious libertine. His most famous in Amorata was a Jewish princess called Berenice. But when he becomes emperor, it's kind of like Prince Hal in Henry IV part two,
在世界上游荡，无法得到安抚。因此，提图斯迫切需要安抚这些未被埋葬的死者的灵魂。我认为毫无疑问，当他为斗兽场揭幕时，他不仅是作为一名盛大的仪式主持人，一个为人民提供娱乐的人，而是作为帝国和城市的道德守护者。所以提图斯在成为皇帝之前名声其实很差。他曾是禁卫军的首领，也就是皇家卫队，这让他名声不佳。他曾是一个臭名昭著的浪荡子。他最著名的情人是一位名叫贝勒尼基的犹太公主。但当他成为皇帝后，就像《亨利四世》第二部中的哈尔王子一样，
he turns over a new leaf and says, basically, I am going to be good. So when he accepts the office of Pontifex Maximus, which is the chief priesthood in the Roman state, he declares that he is motivated by one thing and one thing only, which is he never wants to pollute his hands with blood. That's very un-Roman, Tom. Well, except that it's very ostentatious, and to be ostentatious in your programs is very Roman. Right. So he has a habit of lying around at dinner, and he'll say things like, oh, my friends, I have wasted a day, for I have done nothing good. I'm like that. Yeah, I know. I know you are. So very, very Titus behavior. And so he's kind of widely reported as saying things like that. Yeah, I know. I know you are. So very, very Titus behavior. And so he's kind of
他改过自新，基本上说，我要做一个好人。所以当他接受大祭司这一罗马国家最高祭司职位时，他宣称自己只受一个动机驱使，那就是他永远不想让自己的双手沾满鲜血。这很不罗马，汤姆。嗯，除了这非常炫耀，而在你的节目中炫耀是非常罗马的。对。所以他有在晚餐时躺着的习惯，他会说诸如“哦，我的朋友们，我浪费了一天，因为我没做任何好事”之类的话。我就像那样。是啊，我知道。我知道你是。所以这是非常非常提图斯的行为。所以他被广泛报道说出这样的话。是啊，我知道。我知道你是。所以这是非常非常
widely reported as saying things like this. It obviously comes from his own propagandists. And when he inaugurates the Colosseum, people whom he had employed as the head of the Praetorians, kind of informers, the apparatus of spy craft that had been serving to uphold the Flavian regime. All these people are dragged into the arena. They are smashed up with cudgels. They are lashed with whips. And this is, again, making an absolutely public statement to the mass of the Roman people that Titus is no longer the man he was, that this is all about doing right by the Roman people, but more importantly, doing right by the gods. And it's because of that, that what you were fixing on, the seating aspect is so important because a city in chaos is a city that is going to anger the gods. So Titus is, as Augustus was, obsessed with everyone having the right place.
广泛报道说出这样的话。这显然来自他自己的宣传人员。当他为斗兽场揭幕时，那些他曾雇佣为禁卫军首领的人，那些告密者，那些一直服务于维护弗拉维政权的间谍机构的人。所有这些人被拖进竞技场。他们被棍棒殴打。他们被鞭子抽打。这再次向广大罗马人民发表了一个绝对公开的声明：提图斯不再是以前那个人了，这一切都是为了罗马人民行正义，但更重要的是，为了神灵行正义。正因为如此，你所关注的座位问题才如此重要，因为一个混乱的城市是一个会激怒神灵的城市。所以提图斯就像奥古斯都一样，执着于每个人都有合适的位置。
Senators have to be in the right place. The poor have to be right at the top, women, slaves, whatever. They all have to be. It's a census that is now embodied in stone. Okay. So that's the seating. What are people watching? So my sense of it, Tom, as a complete outsider to the subject and someone who loves the film Gladiator, is that you've got a few men in chariots. You've got a bloke with a net and a trident. You've got the other fellow with his sword. You've got a few tigers or whatever roaming around underneath and then suddenly being disgorged out of grills. What's going on? Everything. I mean, it is stupefying. These are the greatest spectacles ever staged. And I think that what Titus is doing, again, it's a repudiation of Nero,
元老必须在正确的位置。穷人必须在最顶层，妇女、奴隶等等。他们都必须各就各位。这是一种现在体现在石头上的普查。好的。这就是座位。人们在看什么？所以我的感觉是，汤姆，作为一个完全的外行，一个喜欢电影《角斗士》的人，你看到几个男人在战车上。你看到一个拿着网和三叉戟的家伙。你看到另一个拿着剑的家伙。你看到几只老虎之类的东西在下面游荡，然后突然从格栅里被放出来。发生了什么？一切。我的意思是，这令人目瞪口呆。这是有史以来上演的最伟大的奇观。我认为提图斯所做的，再次是对尼禄的否定，
and it's an affirmation of the fact that the Roman people have to align themselves with the gods. What Nero had done when he took to the stage and played on the lyre or took a dramatic role was that he was identifying himself with the heroes of myth. What Titus is doing is often basically restaging the dimension of myth in the arena. is doing is often kind of basically restaging the dimension of myth in the arena and that in turn is to cast him and the roman people in the role in in the part of the gods it's actually people do this thing then they could live action role playing or cosplaying or whatever they call it where they dress up as yeah they dress up as people from the viking heroes characters in star, and they do what they do in woods or
是对罗马人民必须与神灵保持一致这一事实的肯定。尼禄登上舞台弹奏里拉琴或扮演戏剧角色时，他是在将自己与神话英雄等同起来。而提图斯所做的，基本上是在竞技场中重现神话的维度。这反过来又将他和罗马人民置于神灵的角色中。实际上人们会做这种事，他们可以进行真人角色扮演或Cosplay，或者随便叫什么，他们打扮成维京英雄、星球大战里的角色，然后在树林里做他们做的事。
wherever they do it. This is a kind of version of that. So it's a version of role-playing. They would dress up as heroes, as characters from history. So if the Roman people are the gods watching the spectacle of mortals on the earth, then the criminals and the slaves who are entertaining them are often being cast in the role of tragic heroes, heroes from myth, and so on. So there isn't a set routine, but the whole point with staging spectacular is that you mix things up. But you could say that there's a rhythm that is more obeyed than disregarded, which is that you open with displays of execution. And again, these are seen by the Romans as being an expression of the correct way to do things. Livy says of the Romans that we may boast above any other people that our methods
这是一种版本。所以这是一种角色扮演。他们会打扮成英雄，打扮成历史人物。如果罗马人民是观看地球上凡人奇观的神灵，那么娱乐他们的罪犯和奴隶往往被塑造成悲剧英雄、神话英雄等等。所以没有固定的套路，但上演奇观的全部意义在于你要把事情混合起来。但你可以说有一种节奏是被遵守多于被忽视的，那就是你以处决表演开始。同样，这些在罗马人看来是正确行事方式的表达。李维曾说罗马人可以自豪地宣称，我们的惩罚方法
of punishment are civilized, which may come as a surprise to us because we tend to think that Roman punishments are incredibly uncivilized. But it is important to the Romans that executions affirm a moral order. What is happening in the Colosseum is that this kind of ambition to make executions affirm a kind of sense that all is right with the world is being fused with the dimension of myth. So in effect, what they're staging, it's a kind of combination of a snuff movie with Cirque du Soleil. It's capital punishment fused with brilliant stagecraft.
比任何其他民族都文明，这可能会让我们感到惊讶，因为我们倾向于认为罗马的惩罚极其不文明。但对罗马人来说，重要的是处决要维护一种道德秩序。在斗兽场发生的事情是，这种让处决确认世界一切正常的野心，正在与神话的维度融合。所以实际上，他们上演的是一种“鼻烟电影”与“太阳马戏团”的结合。这是死刑与精湛舞台艺术的融合。
I suppose it's the stagecraft and the spectacle that lifts it to the level of a ritual rather than merely, oh, here's some guy who stole some bread, we'll cut his hands off or cut his head off. It's both. Again, it's having cake and eating it. Marshall loves these. We know about these punishments, these executions, because Marshall writes about them. So for instance, he describes a man who is chained by his wrists and by his ankles and a bear comes and gnaws out his intestines. So there's echoes there of the punishment of Prometheus whose intestines were gnawed by a vulture or an eagle. There is a woman who is mounted by a bull. And again, I mean, quite how that is staged, what that involved. I mean, there've been many scholarly attempts to make sense of that. But that again is a story that comes from Greek mythology.
我想是舞台艺术和奇观将其提升到了仪式的层面，而不仅仅是“哦，这里有个偷面包的家伙，我们要砍掉他的手或头”。两者兼而有之。这又是鱼与熊掌兼得。马提雅尔喜欢这些。我们知道这些惩罚，这些处决，因为马提雅尔写过它们。例如，他描述了一个手腕和脚踝被锁住的人，一只熊过来啃食他的内脏。这与普罗米修斯的惩罚有呼应，他的内脏被秃鹫或老鹰啃食。有一个女人被公牛骑跨。同样，我的意思是，这究竟是如何上演的，涉及什么。我的意思是，有很多学术尝试来理解这一点。但这又是来自希腊神话的故事。
Is that Europa? The story of Europa? No, it's the story of Pacify, the queen who gives birth to the Minotaur. Oh, of course. Yes, yes, yes, yes. So Marshall writes of this, let decrepit antiquity boast all it likes, whatever has story at pacify the queen who gives birth to the minor of course yes yes yes yes so um marshall writes of this let decrepit antiquity boast all it likes whatever has been rendered famous by song caesar has been reproduced in the arena for you so it's the feeling that the roman people have entered a dimension of mythology controlled by caesar and they don't view it well our senses of course who knows what's going through their heads but but our sense is that they don't view this as pure fancy dress reenactment, a sort of very sinister and dark reenactment of mythology.
那是欧罗巴吗？欧罗巴的故事？不，是帕西法厄的故事，那个生下米诺陶洛斯的王后。哦，当然。是的，是的，是的，是的。所以马提雅尔写道：让衰老的古代尽情吹嘘吧，无论什么被歌声渲染得著名，凯撒都为你再现于竞技场。所以这是一种感觉，罗马人民进入了一个由凯撒控制的神话维度，他们并不认为这——好吧，我们的感官当然，谁知道他们脑子里在想什么，但我们的感觉是，他们并不认为这纯粹是奇装异服的重演，而是一种非常阴险和黑暗的神话重演。
These are rituals that to some degree occupy a space between the natural and the supernatural. Is that right? I think so. I mean, I'm sure that there are people who just love the spectacle of blood. So Claudius was notorious for adoring executions. Which is funny because he's such an unbelligerent and weedy man. Well, so if you just read, you know, I Claudius, you'd never have that sense. But Suetonius is very specific and he comments on it because it's unusual. Executions are seen as being a bit vulgar, a bit crass. But these executions are clearly, in terms of stagecraft, designed as
这些仪式在某种程度上占据了自然与超自然之间的空间。是这样吗？我想是的。我的意思是，我相信有些人只是喜欢血腥的奇观。克劳狄斯就以热爱处决而闻名。这很有趣，因为他是一个如此不好战且虚弱的人。嗯，如果你读过《我，克劳狄斯》，你永远不会有那种感觉。但苏维托尼乌斯非常具体，他对此发表了评论，因为这很不寻常。处决被视为有点粗俗，有点粗鲁。但这些处决在舞台艺术方面显然被设计为
works of art. So you have the entertainment value. But I think you're absolutely right that, yes, there is a kind of sense that you're in the border zone of the supernatural here. And that, of course, makes it all the more thrilling. Now, the other thing that is part of the entertainment is hinted at by the presence of a bear tearing out the intestines. The bear is specified, this comes from Caledonia, from what's now Scotland. And by bringing monsters from the barbarian reaches that lie beyond the empire, or from the outermost reaches of the empire itself, what the Caesars are doing is demonstrating the global reach of Roman power. Those animals that are brought to Rome, they're fierce in themselves. Imagine seeing a giraffe for the first time. It's a remarkable
艺术品。所以你有娱乐价值。但我认为你绝对是对的，是的，有一种感觉，你正处于超自然的边界地带。当然，这让它更加令人兴奋。现在，娱乐的另一部分被那只撕开内脏的熊的存在所暗示。熊被特别指出，来自喀里多尼亚，也就是现在的苏格兰。通过从帝国之外的蛮荒之地，或从帝国最遥远的边缘带来怪物，凯撒们所做的是展示罗马力量的全球影响力。那些被带到罗马的动物，它们本身就很凶猛。想象一下第一次看到长颈鹿。这是一个非凡的
spectacle. But there is also a sense that, aren't we great? We can bring all these animals. And there's a wonderful passage in The Satyricon, which is a novel written by Petronius, who was the most stylish man at Nero's court, inevitably had to end up committing suicide. He has this great passage of poetry in it, where he writes about the wild animal being hunted out in the woods at exorbitant price, and men trouble Hamon, which is a generic name for a trader, far away in deepest Africa to supply that beast whose tusks are more valuable than the lives of those who hunt him. So that's elephants. Strange ravening creatures are born by our fleets and the padding tiger is wheeled in a gilded palace to drink human blood while the crowd applauds and
奇观。但也有这样一种感觉：我们不是很伟大吗？我们可以带来所有这些动物。在佩特罗尼乌斯所著的小说《萨蒂利孔》中有一段精彩的段落，他是尼禄宫廷中最时髦的人，不可避免地最终自杀。他在书中有一段伟大的诗句，写到野兽在森林中以高昂的价格被猎杀，人们麻烦哈蒙——这是一个商人的通用名称——远在非洲深处去供应那头象牙比猎人生命更珍贵的野兽。所以那是大象。奇怪的贪婪生物被我们的舰队运来，行走的虎被推入镀金的宫殿饮用人血，而人群鼓掌和
cheers. So actually the tigers in Gladiator in the film are not anachronistic. I always thought they were anachronistic, but they really are bringing these creatures into the arena. Yep. So tigers come from India. Huge snakes come from India. Elephants, of course, brought from India and from Africa. So yeah, this is about displaying Rome's global reach. And then you have the gladiators. And the gladiators are the climax of the entertainment, usually. This is what people have come to see because it is sport. It is about skill. People will have their favourites.
欢呼。所以实际上电影《角斗士》里的老虎并不是时代错误。我一直以为它们是时代错误，但他们确实把这些生物带进了竞技场。是的。所以老虎来自印度。巨大的蛇来自印度。大象当然是从印度和非洲带来的。所以是的，这是关于展示罗马的全球影响力。然后你有角斗士。角斗士通常是娱乐的高潮。这是人们来看的原因，因为这是运动。这是关于技巧的。人们会有他们最喜欢的。
And that sense that you get often in sport at its most intense, whether it's boxing or if you're a cricket fan, very fast bowling aimed at the head. The sense of physical danger, I think for sports fans, even if they don't admit it, is often part of the excitement. Well, how many people watch Formula One racing and love the crashes? And there is, I think I mentioned it before, there is this brilliant account many centuries later after the Coliseum is inaugurated. But I think true to the psychology of perhaps how the crowds were affected, written by St.
那种你在最激烈的运动中得到的感觉，无论是拳击，还是如果你是板球迷，瞄准头部的非常快的投球。我认为对于体育迷来说，即使他们不承认，身体危险的感觉往往是兴奋的一部分。嗯，有多少人看一级方程式赛车并喜欢撞车？而且，我想我之前提到过，在斗兽场揭幕几个世纪后，有一段精彩的描述。但我认为这真实地反映了观众可能受到的心理影响，由圣奥古斯丁写关于他的一位朋友阿里皮乌斯，他后来像奥古斯丁一样，成为了一位非常杰出的基督教主教和思想家。但他描述了阿里皮乌斯对角斗娱乐非常冷淡。他没兴趣看。然后他被说服进去。他坐在那里，闭着眼睛，因为他不想看，然后奥古斯丁描述了当他看到血时，他的眼睛睁开了，当他看到血时，他带着野蛮的脾气喝下了它，
Augustine about a friend of his called Olypius, who goes on to become like Augustine, a very distinguished Christian bishop and thinker. But he describes how Olypius is very standoffish about gladiatorial entertainments. He's not interested in seeing it. And then he gets persuaded to go in. And he sits there, his eyes shut because he doesn't interested in seeing it then he gets persuaded to go in and he sits there his eyes shut because he doesn't want to watch it and then augustine describes how as soon as he saw the blood he kind of his eyes open as soon as he saw the blood he drank it in with a savage temper and
他没有转过身，而是盯着血腥的消遣，沉浸在疯狂中，对邪恶的竞赛感到高兴，沉醉于嗜血。他不再是那个进来时的人，而是暴民中的一员。他成为了带他来的人的真正同伴。我还需要多说什么吗？他看了，他喊了，他很兴奋，他带走了会刺激他再次前来的疯狂。虽然那是关于阿里皮乌斯的，但我认为几乎可以肯定奥古斯丁是在写他自己，所以他在《忏悔录》中写了这一点。这就是它的吸引力。这就是暴力的快感。我记得我在做关于伊斯兰国的节目时，我正在研究他们制作的“鼻烟视频”。有一个特别可怕，当一名约旦飞行员被俘时，我不记得你是否记得，他被关进了一个笼子里活活烧死。
he did not turn away but fixed his eyes on the bloody pastime drinking in the madness delighted with the wicked contest drunk with bloodlust he was now no longer the same man who came in but was one of the mob he came into a true companions of those who had brought him there why need i say more he looked he shouted he was excited and he took away with him the madness that would stimulate him to come again and although that is about lippis i think it's almost certainly augustine is writing about himself so he's writing this in his confessions. This is the appeal of it. This is the thrill of violence. And I remember when I was doing my program about the Islamic State, I was researching the snuff videos that they made. And there was one that was particularly horrible as a Jordanian pilot got captured, I don't know if you remember, and he got put in a kind of cage and burnt alive.
但当然，西方人质的斩首也在互联网上定期传播。我读到过一些统计数据，关于那些视频中被处死的人的名字在谷歌上搜索的频率在几周后有多高。人们想看。太可怕了。人们在查找它。我认为这延续了玛丽所说的，当你引用她的话时，如果我们认为我们已经摆脱了那种欲望，那我们就是在自欺欺人。我认为如果上演角斗，人们绝对会去看。我们离人们观看绞刑并不遥远，汤姆。当然，
But of course, the beheadings of the Western hostages as well were kind of regularly going out on the internet. And I read some statistic about just how popular a search term, the name of those who were put to death on those videos were on Google for weeks afterwards. People wanted to see it. Terrifying. People were looking it up. And I think that, you that, this is kind of following on from what Mary said when you quoted her, that we fool ourselves if we think that we have outgrown that lust. I think if gladiatorial combats were staged, people would absolutely watch them. We're not that far away from people watching hangings, Tom. And of course,
有些国家仍然有公开绞刑或斩首之类的，人类会填满体育场去观看。但重申一下，我认为角斗不仅仅是关于娱乐。它们不仅仅是关于运动。它们作为安抚死者灵魂的仪式所扮演的角色，我认为这是庞贝和赫库兰尼姆毁灭后所发生事情的重要组成部分。它在非常非常意想不到的地方显现出来。例如，你在医学书籍中能看到它。这是克劳狄斯的医生，一个叫斯克里博尼乌斯·拉尔格斯的人。他描述了一些人如何服用从倒下的角斗士身上切下的小剂量肝脏，剂量为九倍。所以一个死去的角斗士被认为
there are countries where hangings are still public or beheadings or whatever, and human people will fill stadiums to watch them. But to reiterate, I think that the gladiatorial combats are not just about entertainment. They're not just about sport. The role that they are playing as rights that appease the souls of the dead, this is an important part, I think, of what is going on in the wake of the destruction of Pompeii and Herculaneum. It's kind of manifest in very, very unexpected places. For instance, you get it in medical books. This is the physician of Claudius, the doctor of Claudius, a man called Scribonius Largus. He describes how some people take a nine times dosage of a small quantity of liver cut from a fallen gladiator. So a dead gladiator is seen to
对你的健康有好处。当然，另一件事在《角斗士》中绝对明显，那就是角斗士的身影非常非常色情。所以喜欢角斗士的女性是罗马讽刺文学的绝对主食。尤维纳利斯，最伟大的罗马讽刺作家，总是谈论它。罗马道德家们一直担心人们会被角斗士性吸引，事实上罗马贵族会想成为角斗士。除了色情吸引力，角斗士有粉丝吗？所以在电影《角斗士》中，当他最初，马克西姆斯最初被称为“西班牙人”时。其中一个设计是，帝国的年轻继承人，名叫卢修斯，卢修斯·费里斯，我想，有一种执念。
be good for your health. And of course, the other thing which again is absolutely manifest in gladiator is that the figure of the gladiator is very, very erotic. So women who fancy gladiators are an absolute staple of Roman satire. Juvenal, the greatest Roman satirist, is always going on about it. And it's a kind of constant anxiety of Roman moralists that the people will be sexually attracted to gladiators, and indeed the Roman nobleman will want to be gladiators. And apart from the erotic appeal, do gladiators have fans? So in the film Gladiator, when he's initially, Maximus is initially called the Spaniard. One of the devices is that the young heir to the empire, who's called Lucius, Lucius Ferris, I think, has a fixation.
西班牙人是他最喜欢的角斗士。他是西班牙人的粉丝。那会奏效吗？你认为人们会有粉丝吗？是的，绝对。对。角斗士相当于体育明星。你会支付溢价去看最好的，就像现在一样。人们想看最好的运动员。他们会付更多的钱。这更
The Spaniard is his favorite gladiator. He's a fan of the Spaniard. Would that have worked? Do you think people would have fans? Yes, absolutely. Right. Gladiators are the equivalent of sports stars. And you would pay a premium to see the best, as now. People want to see the best sportsmen. They will pay more money. It's more
有声望。斗兽场里的人不付钱。他们得到票和凭证。这是他们公民权利的一部分。但顶级角斗士战斗的日子，就是你想去占位子的日子。所以关于斗兽场，我刚才读到，斗兽场，最后一次角斗比赛是在公元435年左右提到的。基督教已经成为罗马帝国的国教。基督徒会去吗，尽管可能作为一种罪恶的快感，也许？不。我的意思是，如果你是主教，可能不会。
prestigious. People in the Coliseum aren't paying. They're getting tickets and dockets. It's part of their civic right. But days on which top gladiators are fighting, those are the days that you want to go and get your place. So just on the Colosseum, I'm just reading here, the Colosseum, the last gladiatorial fights are mentioned around the year 435. Christianity has become the state religion of the Roman Empire. Would Christians go, despite maybe as a guilty pleasure, maybe? No. I mean, maybe not if you're a bishop. Probably.
我认为总的来说，对于基督徒来说，这不仅仅是因为这些是血腥的暴力展示。不仅仅是因为奴隶的处决令人不安地让人想起罗马人对耶稣所做的事情。这也是一种持久的感觉，即这些战斗具有神圣的意义，如果我可以使用那个短语的话。你当然可以。谢谢。所以显然它构成了威胁。
I think by and large for Christians, it's not just that these are violent displays of blood. It's not just that the execution of slaves is unsettlingly reminiscent of what the Romans did to Jesus. It's also the enduring sense that these combats have a sacral significance, if I may use that phrase. You may indeed. Thank you. So obviously it threatens.
是的，这是一个——好吧，如果你去那里，你就是在参与一个旨在安抚死者的仪式。对。那不太像基督徒。所以关于斗兽场，斗兽场在五世纪后，当罗马本身作为城市处于上升期时，我想它陷入了相对的废弃。我的意思是，后来，正如你所说，它变成了一座城堡，弗兰吉帕尼家族的城堡。弗兰吉帕尼家族。
Yes, it's a- Well, if you go there, you are taking part in a ritual that is designed to appease the dead. Right. And that's not very Christian. So on the Colosseum, the Colosseum falls into a relative disuse, I guess, after the fifth century when Rome itself is on its up as the city. I mean, later on, as you said, it becomes a castle, the castle of the Francopans. The Francopans.
是的。但在那之前，它一度是一座小教堂。这显然是因为人们认为这是基督徒殉道的地方。不确定。我认为基督徒殉道的想法要晚得多。我想是18世纪。也许。是的，我认为那是18世纪发生的事情。对。
Yeah. But before that, it's a chapel at one point. And that's obviously because people think this was the place where Christians were martyred. Not sure. I think the idea that Christians were martyred is much later. I think it's the 18th century. Maybe. Yes, I think it's the 18th century that that happens. Right.
但我认为斗兽场一直被视为罗马的象征，因为它是那里最宏伟的纪念碑。那种它是罗马版大教堂的想法。它是这座城市在石头上的伟大宣言。它巨大的规模意味着当其他建筑倒塌时，它不会倒塌。是的。所以尽管它现在是废墟，但它仍然是一个非凡的奇观，不是吗？我的意思是，它是一个巨大的采石场，但它太巨大了，以至于即使大块的石头被运走，它仍然保留了它一直以来的形式，一直延续到今天。虽然我们做了很多与足球的类比，显然很多足球场看起来确实像斗兽场，实际上，如果它们是
But I think the Colosseum is always seen as the emblem of Rome because it's the vastest monument there. That idea that it is the Roman equivalent of a cathedral. It's that kind of great statement in stone of what the city is. And the sheer size of it means it doesn't collapse when other buildings do. Yeah. So even though it's in ruins now, it's still an extraordinary spectacle, isn't it? I mean, it's a huge quarry, but it's so enormous that even though chunks of the stone gets carted away, it retains the form that it always had right the way up to the present day. Although we've made a lot of analogies with football, and obviously a lot of football stadiums do look like the Coliseum, actually, if they're a lot of analogies with football, and obviously a lot of football stadiums do look like the Coliseum, actually, if they're a sort of bowl shape.
碗状的话。也许更好的类比实际上是斗牛场。因为斗牛，我想在斗兽场的历史上曾有过讨论，在近代早期，把它变成一个斗牛场。它从未发生过。是的，我想其中一位教皇想那样做。教皇们！而且那不是一个绝对好的主意。所以那被否决了。
Maybe a better analogy is actually the bullfighting arena. Because bullfighting, there was talk at one point in the Coliseum's history, I think, about turning it in the early modern period, turning it into a bullfighting arena. It never happened. Yeah, one of the popes, I think, wanted to do that. The popes! And he was not an infallibly good idea. So that was kibosh.
是的。所以斗牛，我认为是你所能得到的最接近角斗体验的东西。对于斗牛爱好者来说，这不仅仅是关于暴力，甚至可能主要不是关于暴力。这是关于体育精神、技巧、专业知识的展示。奇观。是的。我认为这可能适用于斗兽场上演的许多表演。是的。这既是一个壮观的故事，
Yeah. So bullfighting, I think, is the closest that you would get to what the experience of gladiatorial combat would be. And for aficionados of bullfighting, it's not just about the violence, it's not even perhaps mainly about the violence. It's about the sportsmanship, the skill, the display of expertise. Spectacle. Yes. And I think that that's probably true to a lot of the displays that were put on in the Coliseum. Yeah. It's both a spectacular story,
但它确实是一个相当令人不安的故事，不是吗？仅仅想到那些必定已经死亡的人数。我的意思是，成千上万的人，我假设在它的历史过程中，成千上万的动物被屠杀。是的。汤姆？为了罗马假日而屠杀，拜伦这样写道。是的。可怕的事情是，我经常想这个问题，如果你去罗马度假，而他们带回了角斗比赛，会有多少人去？是的。会有多少人去？嗯，我们谈论过这个，我想在我们为俱乐部成员准备的奖励剧集之一中，我们被问到，你会回到过去哪里，所有这些东西，当然问题是
but it is quite an unsettling one, isn't it? Just thinking about the sheer, the numbers of people who must have died. I mean, thousands of people, I assume over the course of its history, thousands of animals that were butchered. Yeah. Tom? Butchered to make a Roman holiday, Byron put it. Yeah. The scary thing is, I often think about this, if you went on holiday to Rome and they had brought back gladiatorial games, how many people would go? Yeah. How many people would go? Well, we talked about this when we talked, I think on one of our bonus episodes for our club members, we were asked, where would you go back in time and all this sort of stuff and the question of course is
如果你回到公元二世纪，你知道你因为神秘博士之类的东西去度了一个长周末，如果比赛正在进行，你会去看吗？我认为这是一个非常难以回答的问题，因为你总有一部分人在想，天哪，这是一个非凡的体验，可以看到它，但同时，它的恐怖，我的意思是，如果现在特拉法加广场有公开处决，我不会去看。我的意思是，奥古斯丁关于那个人去看它的描述，我的意思是，这听起来几乎就像吸食海洛因之类的。你知道你不应该，但你还是吸了，然后你就上瘾了。
if you went back in time to the second century ad you know you've gone for a long weekend courtesy of doctor who or something would you go and see the games if they were on and i think that's a really difficult one to answer because there's always a part of you that's thinking god this is a you know extraordinary experience to see it but at the same time the horror of it i mean i wouldn't answer because there's always a part of you that's thinking, God, this is an extraordinary experience to see it, but at the same time, the horror of it. I mean, I wouldn't go to watch public execution now if there were public executions in Trafalgar Square. I mean, that account by Augustine of the man going to see it, I mean, it makes it sound almost like taking heroin or something. You know you shouldn't, but then you take it and you're addicted.
嗯，恐惧不是，恐惧不是，恐惧不是你会去然后你会讨厌它。恐惧是你去了然后你会享受它。是的。这才是真正令人不寒而栗的想法。好的。所以如果你想阅读更多关于斗兽场的内容，你当然可以，而且你应该——哦，多米尼克。去你最近的书店，投资一本，或者确实为朋友和家人购买多本汤姆·霍兰德的书《帕克斯》。哦，你对我太好了。
Well, isn't the fear, isn't the fear, the fear is not that you'll go and you'll hate it. The fear is that you'll go and you'll enjoy it. Yeah. Which is the really chilling thought. Okay. So if you want to read more about the Coliseum, you can, of course, and you should- Oh, Dominic. Go to your nearest bookshop and invest in a copy or indeed multiple copies for friends and family of Tom Holland's book, Pax. Oh, you're being so nice to me.
嗯，我是在为你做铺垫，汤姆。就是这样。这一切都是关于罗马在其权力和声望的巅峰时期。它是关于斗兽场。它是关于庞贝。它是关于所有这些令人兴奋的事情。皇帝提图斯、图密善和韦斯巴芗等等。伟大的场景。
Well, I'm softening you up for stuff, Tom. That's what it is. It's all about Rome at the height of its power and prestige. It's about the Colosseum. It's about Pompeii. It's about all these exciting things. The Empress Titus and Domitian and Vespasian and so on. Great scenes.
我们下次会回来，不是和罗马人，而是和完全不同的东西，所以我们到时候见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
And we will be back next time time not with the romans but with something completely and utterly different so we'll see you then bye-bye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次再见，届时我们将不再谈论罗马人，而是谈论一些完全不同的东西，那么我们到时候见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。